the jurogan experience the connor aldo
same thing like it's like right to left
just straight across while he's coming
forward makes his head spin the fact
that aldo was so hell-bent on destroying
conor he just was hell-bent and and
conor took advantage of that
i remember that it was like here we go
big fight and there was like one it's
over immediately smiling it's like when
she slaps somebody and then it was
genius but this was a powerful
punishment you first look at that boom
bang bang first of all you got to
realize it's perfectly placed yeah
absolutely
accuracies impeccable second of all some
people can just crack and if you look at
conor's build there's a lot of guys
built like that that can [ __ ] crack i
want to see it in slow motion he's got
he's got real wide shoulders he's real
fast and he's got big hands like all
those things together
he's just got that freakish punch
there's there's just people that just
have that kind of punch man
oh
i mean that's just genius left foot gets
hit afterwards too yeah he had a little
bit of a cut over his right eyebrow from
that punch mm-hmm from all those uh
punch look how genius this is look at
this bam
that's so genius
with one punch he was like
you know what's even more genius
he worked on the exact thing and he
mimicked what he was going to do in the
green room there's video of him of who
connor connor connor pretending to be
aldo and then him showing what he's
going to do and counter
he does the exact move in the green room
knowing in the dressing room knowing
that that's going to be the fight
reminds me of moss vidal ascertain right
oh yeah yeah yeah same thing he he
practiced that step off to the side
she was a great one he was like
it really is when you factor in that
like it gave his career look on the left
that's conor pretended to be aldo and
this is him bam look see
he's literally saying how it's going to
go down he's walking how aldo does and
i want to see both sides now wait let me
see okay look at this
i mean it's literally what he did
he practiced it he he predicted it was
happening
he knew all those movements he had it
time down and he's like much more light
on the foot and as aldo moves forward he
times it perfectly bam look at that yeah
with the right dude that left hand that
left hand is a missile too damn
that left hand's a missile that that guy
he's he's one of the most spectacular
punchers in the history of the sport he
has some punch ko victories who
conor yeah his one when he beat eddie
alvarez show that you want to see
[ __ ] genius striking with the hands
it's genius [ __ ] like you could see
eddie alvarez just got bewildered by it
i mean the the combinations he hit him
with wow just subtly avoiding alvarez's
punches genius [ __ ]
genius
dude he was i used to love rooting
against him
he was such a good heel too yeah he was
a cheer for diaz oh
guy he's the best healer he got
everybody into it
yeah he's the best he'll ever
we're like [ __ ] i hope you got your
comeuppance
he just never would dude i'm telling you
when you watch this combination it's
[ __ ] watch it's look at the sidekick
to the body i mean he's hitting him with
all kinds of [ __ ] he's so light on his
feet like this is prime conor in my
opinion she's so light on his feet
look at these combinations watch this
just like just it's just getting just
out of the way like eddie can't touch
him he hit him there though
but it's connor just looking for the
opening
but not enough to hurt him now they're
saying boom
that was
[Music]
you know people get all wrapped up in
all the personality and the flash and
the money and the rolls royces and
everything that [ __ ] could fight
he could fight
and guys have beat him but you got to be
like an elite of the elite you got to be
like a khabib or a poor yeah you got to
be
top of the food chain to beat them
go towards the end of this
yeah i just want to see that
i just wanted the final combo
this is what i wanted
because the finish of this fight
is legendary it's like in highlight
reels all over the place look at this oh
look at that combo
look at that combo show me that again
watch this look at this he just slides
in on
here boom him boom i mean come on there
she slides just out of the way the punch
lands
four or five right ruthless punches
perfectly placed let me see one more
time oh okay
look at this look at it it actually
touches his chin he doesn't even flinch
one two
three the accuracy full punches four
and just swarms on him and perfect
placement right there's no extra wind up
that would would have made a mess look
at this bing bing
bing bang look at me this [ __ ] that's
amazing it goes from fine to cut up bro
that's an amazing combination that's an
amazing combination
what happened to him got [ __ ]
fights man fights happened to him yeah
and then also a [ __ ] ton of money and
then also sometime out of the game while
i was doing the floyd mayweather thing
you know he trained for quite a while
for floyd mayweather which was i'm sure
just doing boxing if you're going to
play you know you're going to train for
a giant 100 million dollar fight you're
most likely not going to do any you know
mma sparring or anything probably just
did that for a while
and then you get that money what's that
marvin hagler quote about it's hard to
get up at five in the morning
and go running when you're sleeping in
silk sheets i think that's the
that's him now he's super jacked
whoa usada's gonna take it
wait took a visit that's connor yeah
right now
oh dude he looks like he's about to go
wwf yeah he looks like a bodybuilder
well 70s it's a weird picture honestly i
mean he's definitely jacked but it looks
to me like he's the middle of lifting
and if you uh if you see a guy's body in
the middle of lifting it's a little
deceptive because everything see that's
what he looks like now he's still jacked
he still looks great
but when you're um when you lift weights
like as you do it like those
bodybuilders that go on stage before
those uh big
mr olympia things they all get pumped
opioids
look at him he looks good though whoa he
looks so old now he looks different yeah
he's got that crease
that beard's crazy
yeah but he looks fit is he tucking up
his shorts to let his dick come out he's
got a hog i bet
he's going to hug him
shorts he's uh looks like he's walking
around on that shin i wonder uh like
what percentage healed it is you got to
feel like if a bone breaks in half like
that and then you get like a metal plate
to hold it in place and all these screws
and [ __ ] yeah that's got to take a while
you